packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on right
tonight is all about keeping it simple
keeping it simple in the kitchen doesn't
mean you can't have amazing food that
not only looks incredible but tastes
fantastic too
my first recipe is so easy it removes
the stress from cooking and is a
pleasure to make chili beef lettuce
wraps
cooking should never be a chore the more
you cook the more confident you become
that way you actually start to enjoy it
and that's the key to good cooking have
a bit of fun along the way
this is minced beef and minced pork the
pork needs to sit in there otherwise the
going to dry out
really important to season the mints
before you cook it
pan nice and hot
a touch of olive oil
mince in
breaking up like that really helps to
sort of separate it so we can fry it off
with a lot of color
with your spoon
just go through
[Music]
and start breaking that up
the most important thing to remember is
mint is made up of cheap cuts brisket
belly
short rib so
it needs help
and frying off the mince for color is so
important
if this pan wasn't hot your mince is
going to boil there's a horrible gray
color on there
and there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit
[Music]
tastes delicious it's seasoned
beautifully see how crispy it's going
take it
much further than you've ever taken
mince before nice and crispy
smells incredible
and draining it is crucial it keeps the
mince nice and crispy and you get rid of
that
excess fat
that's lovely
now just wipe out the pan then wash it
low gas
now we're going to add texture to the
mince
finely chopped chili
ginger
garlic and spring onions
spring onions give this sort of mince a
really nice freshness
because it just gives that crunch
nice and thinly
now i'm gonna fry off the chilis the
ginger the garlic first
sesame seed oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in
fry that off nicely
the sesame seed oil just lifts up the
whole flavour
brown sugar that starts to really
caramelize the chili the garlic and the
ginger
mince in
now
my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness
you can see now why it's so important to
get that minced really crispy because
nothing's going soggy staying really
crispy
fresh lime
that makes the mince fragrant
and then
lime juice roll it
and squeeze that in there
[Music]
incredible i've got the salty
i've got the heat
i've got the sweetness now i've got the
acidicness as well and then finally my
spring onions in right at the last
minute so i've got crunch in there as
well smells
amazing
literally cook the mince now with sort
of 30 seconds
to go
gas off and take it out
looks incredible smells so inviting
[Music]
to go with the chili beef i'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce so
everyone can dress the crispy mince to
their own taste
dipping sauce a teaspoon
the brown sugar soy sauce
gives it a nice sort of dark rich color
sesame seed oil
a tablespoon and just top that up with a
tablespoon
of olive oil that stops the sesame seed
all becoming too rich
a teaspoon
of fish sauce and then a touch of chili
leave the seeds in again i want the heat
in that sauce
so impressive an amazing show off center
piece
lime juice in
in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up
just check the seasoning
that's lovely nice and rich
now the lettuce i'm going to use baby
gem because it's really nice and durable
and sort of quite strong
so you just sort of sit
these nice
trimmed lettuce leaves
around
now the exciting part serve take your
lettuce up
spoon in
your mince
and then
a little touch of dressing
just a little drizzle
nice and that's the secret of having
good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself
food that looks and tastes a million
bucks doesn't have to be complex
this dish is as fun to cook as it is to
eat
[Music]
one of the keys to keeping it simple is
to prepare all the ingredients in
advance the more organized you are in
the kitchen the easier cooking becomes
here are three of my favorite quick
recipes that with a bit of advanced
preparation are so simple to make
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
starting with my easy fragrant fried
rice
first get prepped
chopped garlic
ginger and chili
keeping the seeds for extra kick
slice spring onions
chopped spring greens and trim ahead of
broccoli
then whisk two eggs
prep done stir fry on
add a good lug of oil to a hot pan
garlic
ginger
chili
next the spring greens and broccoli
add water to steam
[Music]
then cook rice
this dish is perfect for using leftover
rice
make a well
add the eggs
spring onions
and a dash of fish sauce
[Music]
scramble then mix
season
[Applause]
top with lime and spring onions
[Music]
my fragrant fried rice made simple with
advanced prep and ready in five minutes
my next recipe it pays to get prepped
for is garlic and saffron mayonnaise
[Music]
first get your ingredients to hand
eggs should be out of the fridge and at
room temperature
soak saffron in warm water
saffron is the most expensive spice in
the world
made from the dried stigma of crocus
flowers
but even a pinch gives a fantastic taste
and a wonderful colour
next separate three eggs put the yolks
into a mixing bowl
add dijon mustard
finely chopped garlic
the drained saffron
and a squeeze of lemon
then mix
whisking constantly add oil slowly it
won't take
forever for perfect flavor use half
olive oil and half vegetable oil
when the mayonnaise comes together
season
[Music]
a smooth thick consistency means it's
done
top with saffron
rich delicious and perfect with
everything from seafood to sandwiches
and chips my second recipe
garlic and saffron mayonnaise easy to
get right as long as you've planned
ahead
my final dish that's a cinch to cook
with a little advanced prep work is
mussels with celery and chili
first prep the veg chopped spring onions
shallots
a clove of garlic
and chili to taste
then thinly slice celery
add a bay leaf and thyme veg ready
[Music]
add oil to a pan and fry
[Music]
season
then add mussels and stir
muscles one of my favorite shellfish
cheap healthy and delicious
cover and sting for a couple of minutes
as the muscles open add vermouth and
aromatic 45 wine
[Music]
and 150ml of dry white wine
on a high heat reduce the liquid to
create a source
discard any mussels that are still shut
then finish with creme fresh and chopped
parsley
[Music]
minimal prep and cooked in less than 10
minutes my muscles with celery and chili
impressive affordable and super speedy
make it simple in the kitchen by
prepping your ingredients in advance and
i promise you'll find these three
recipes a pleasure to make
amazing
[Music]
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment
this is my quick guide to kitchen knives
basically three knives a heavy duty
chopping knife
followed by a small paring knife which
is brilliant for prepping vegetables
and then this baby here a serrated edge
knife for carving and slicing
basically that is it
before you buy a knife hold it in your
hand and make sure it feels right for
you
the secret behind a great set of knives
is in the handle if you're comfortable
holding the handle
your cutting can be so much easier the
firmer the grip the better the chopping
the heavier the handle the more control
you've got over the blade
with these three knives you can't go
wrong
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
[Music]
this is my guide to keeping it simple
my next recipe is easy and a pleasure to
make if you're organized with everything
ready in advance
[Music]
miso poached salmon with asian
vegetables
organization is key in the kitchen take
a couple of minutes before you start and
set yourself up make sure you know where
everything is stock spatula pan etc it
becomes less stressful but more
importantly the end results are
incredible
[Music]
first off get your pan on
whisk
and stock
start off with this amazing fermented
soy bean puree
into the pan three nice tablespoons
gas on now get your fish stock and whisk
into the puree
be generous with the stock
you want this nice
light
broth basically
you can buy miso paste from big
supermarkets and it works brilliantly
with salmon
poaching the salmon in the miso stuff
gives it a really nice sort of sweet
earthy
creamy flavor it's incredible bring up
to the bowl
i'm going to infuse the broth and make
it a little bit more fragrant
kaffir lime leaf is very lemony inside
the miso broth
then chopped chili
chili's in
and finely sliced ginger
that's simmering beautifully
now we're gonna poach the salmon
poaching means cooking it in liquid but
it's cooked gently and the secret here
is to keep that salmon skin on if we
took the skin off now the salmon can
actually break up
whilst it's poaching skin side
down i'm just going to slide that in
under
nice
the minute that stock
starts boiling turn it down let it
simmer
take a little ladle and just every
couple of minutes pour over
that makes sure the top of the salmon is
cooked evenly and keeps it nice and
moist
and poaching is one of the most delicate
ways of cooking so you have to handle it
with care
whilst the salmon's poaching in the miso
broth start preparing your vegetables
i'm using tender stem broccoli and bak
choy
i always like to cook the leaf and the
stem separately the leaf is like sort of
spinach and the stem is so much thicker
it's almost as thick as a stick of
celery
so i like to get the stems sliced
just so i've got that nice sort of
christmas
place the leaves together nicely roll
them up
nice and tight and then
slice them down
now my salmon already
the flavor in that broth has been
elevated
now it tastes really fishy got the heat
the chili spiciness the ginger and the
caffeine lime leaf
take your fish slice and place it very
gently underneath the salmon and push it
down fish slices are flexible for that
reason bend it
lift it up
just touch looking for a springy firm
texture and just
sit there on top
and it will touch the broth over it
it stops it from drying out
leave that to cool down for two minutes
bring the stock
back up to the boil broccoli and
bak choy stems
in
a little taste
it's getting better and better and
better
cook the broccoli and the bok choy stems
for one minute and then add the tops in
turn the salmon into your hand
and just peel all that skin off the skin
also helps to keep the salad nice and
moist
then gently flake the salmon that's the
secret behind
poaching everything just stays
so moist
wonderful long shards of pink now
just before we serve
we're going to add our mushrooms these
are enoki mushrooms you can buy these
enoki mushrooms in big supermarkets and
good grocers
slice them off i'm going to put half in
and the other half i'm gonna serve with
the salmon
toasted sesame seed oil put a little
drip in there just rub
and you're just lining almost like a
little coat of varnish start off with
your mushrooms and then my salmon
four nice layers
and then finally
the mushrooms
top with the vegetables and then finally
a nice ladle
that beautiful
really sumptuous
rich stock
lovely
and that is an amazing misu poached
salmon soup
simplify your cooking by getting
organized and amazing food will be
coming out your kitchen every day
and for great food you need great
ingredients
[Music]
next up my shopping guide to getting the
finest fish
when i buy my fish i only want the
freshest and the best
and if anyone knows how to get the best
it's roger kent barbara he's been buying
and selling fish at the world famous
billings gate market in london for over
50 years
i love fish
i think it's the greatest food of all
time i sell literally every variety
there is i could feed you a different
fish
365 days a year this guy really knows
how to sniff out the good from the bad
all fish smell different the longer it's
around
the more fishy it will smell
when it's lovely and fresh
it doesn't smell
whenever you're gonna buy fish don't be
frightened get your nose right into it
don't go like that get it into it smell
it
smells delightful it smells what i call
salmony and it's lovely barramundi it's
a lovely fish the way to tell good fish
is look at it closely it's shining it's
still got the bloom on it his eyes are
as bright as yours look in the gill
lovely and red put it in a bag for the
gentleman please people should always be
asking about their fish
what kind of fish is it where does it
come from a nice salmon 19 pound it's a
bargain at 20 pounds roger's right
salmon's brilliant value and a great
all-rounder really healthy and super
delicious here's a quick look at the
different cuts and how to use them
[Music]
whole salmon always impresses it's
fantastic stuffed and steamed either in
a fish kettle or in the oven wrapped in
foil
steaks are great value and brilliant
baked
a cider salmon is perfect for poaching
home curing or baking in pastry
the fillet is so versatile easy fast to
cook and great for pan frying
smoked salmon delicious cooked or raw i
love it with scrambled eggs
[Music]
broadly there's white fish
and there's oily fish they come under
two different sections here we have
white fish
it's lovely it's cold it's the best cot
in the world it comes to a place called
peterhead it's nice and white the whiter
the better one of the most oily fish
you'll find mackerel there it is
lovely color
with most fish the fresher they are the
harder they are if you're not well and
you're ill
have a mackerel sprats otherwise known
as top hats here we have flat fish and
these are known as place as you can see
they've got spots the redder they are
the fresher they are it really is a
lovely fish to eat king jules couldn't
have better for fish fresh enough for
royalty follow your fishmonger's advice
and you'll never ever have another dodgy
dover sole again
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first how to chop an onion this is the
root that's absolutely crucial leave
that on there if you cut that off the
onion will start to bleed and you'll
start crying rapidly
slice going forward let the weight of
the knife do the work
three fingers
one in front two behind and this part of
the knuckle is going to guide the knife
fingers on top of the onion point the
knife towards the root and try to get
as close to the root as possible nice
long
stroke
and then push the onion back together
push the knife halfway in to the onion
slightly tilt the knife down
one at the top
and then gripping the onion like a
tennis ball holding it together in place
with the weight of the blade to cut
through that onion to get to the base of
the root
again turn it round up and down motion
and that's what we're left there no
waste just the root
and look
there
you've got a really nice finely chopped
onion
so much great cooking depends on
starting with a high enough heat if a
recipe calls for a hot pan put it on
early so it gets smoking hot and always
remember to preheat your oven at least
20 minutes before cooking
clean cook is an efficient cook my tip
for a tidy cooking area is to always
have a waste bowl next to you it saves
you going back and forth to the bin
never add salt to eggs before cooking
them because it ruins the texture and
dulls the colour instead save your
seasoning to the very end
[Music]
the key to cooking meat is to make sure
it's at room temperature before you
begin cook straight from the fridge the
mussel fibers will be tight which
results in tough meat and always let it
rest afterwards so relax is becoming
tender and juicy
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
the frying pan is one of your best
friends it's so versatile in the kitchen
learning to use it with these is a must
and i'm going to show you how
first up my delicious pan fried pork
chops with sweet and sour peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
pan on
get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet sound peppers
go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up trying
to slice a pepper
on the side is a nightmare there's the
center start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look that's what you want
now place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind
pinky holding it down thumb holding it
nice and flat the flatter the vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
and take your time
speed comes
the most important thing
is to get your technique right
red onion
now sweet sour peppers
olive oil in
[Music]
i'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's turn for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt
and pepper
add a tablespoon of sugar sugar helps to
break down the peppers quicker but
caramelize the onions frying them in a
frying pan perfect it's one of the sort
of basic essential tools of any kitchen
because it's so multi-purpose great for
sauteing
tossing
great for cooking fish on meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak it you now start to
see it glistening in a way that it's
starting to caramelize sugar's working
beautifully
that's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you can see the sugar
it's worked it's magic
turn down the gas and add a couple of
tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive
oil let them stew for two to three
minutes
now i want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic just
roll the basil
almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds
i want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now for the pork chops
i want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
curling up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the rind means
the chop stays flat and cooks evenly
point the knife down
flip through it's seasoned them
beautifully
nice large
shards of pepper punch that through
lightly guaranteed that seasoning
is gonna stay there
hot pan touch garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic
take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in
just starting to smoke
top of the chop
in
and lay away from me
nice
keep that heat in the pan
put the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork is staying nice and
flat
turn that over look at that beautiful
i want a little bit of thyme underneath
there
start squeezing that garlic out i want
the flavor coming out
butter in
thin slices of butter
till the pan and baste
so i'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time i'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist and now
look at the color of that butter it's
almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side useful
when they're that thick
three and a half to four minutes each
side
30 seconds from now they're going to be
medium so i'm going to take them out and
let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
[Music]
a nice spoon
of these peppers the basil smells
incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your confidence is going to shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour peppers
the frying pan is so simple but
incredibly useful with this one pan you
can make a million different dishes
the more you cook with your frying pan
the more your confidence will grow
here are three of my favorite easy pan
fried dishes
first up pan fried scallops with crunchy
apple salad
[Music]
get a frying pan smoking hot essential
for quick pan frying
add olive oil
then season scallops with salt and
pepper
starting at the top put clockwise into
the pan so you know which one to turn
first
[Music]
scallops have firm white sweet flesh and
cook in minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
next salad lambs lettuce
matchsticks of apple
seasoning
lemon zest and juice
[Applause]
[Music]
add olive oil then toss
[Music]
turn the scallops when golden go
clockwise around the pan
[Applause]
then squeeze in lemon juice and give the
pan a shake
finish with lemon zest
ready in under 10 minutes my first
pan-fried dish scallops with crunchy
apple salad
my next super simple pan fried recipe is
chicken and chicory and masala sauce
[Music]
season the chicken breasts
add to hot olive oil skin side down lay
away from you to stop the all splashing
sliced chicory this versatile vegetable
can be read all white has a lovely
bitter taste and is great cooked or raw
crush a clove of garlic and add
then sprigs of thyme
[Music]
when the chicken skin is crisp turn over
along with the chicory
for the sauce add masala a sweet
fortified wine from sicily
then 150ml of chicken stock
to make the sauce wonderfully rich and
glossy add butter and simmer for 10
minutes
[Music]
plate up and spoon over the sauce
cooked in under 20 minutes chicken and
chicory in masala sauce
my final dish cooked in the versatile
frying pan is
sea bream with tomato and herb salsa
[Music]
fry fillets of sea bream skin side down
in hot olive oil
if they buckle up press gently down for
perfect even cooking then season
sea bream has firm white flesh perfect
for pan frying
next the salsa
heat olive oil
add half cherry tomatoes
pitted black olives
and season
[Music]
after a minute on a low heat add
coriander basil and lemon
[Music]
combine and leave to infuse
[Music]
as the sea bream cooks it goes opaque
when it's two-thirds from the top turn
over
[Music]
baste fry and it's done
sebring with tomato and herb salsa ready
in under 15 minutes
one pan three simple impressive and
absolutely delicious dishes beautiful
coming up on my ultimate cookery course
along with 100 recipes to stake your
life on i'm going to give you 100 quick
cooking tips to make your life in the
kitchen easier
first up how to keep your knife sharp
it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife sharpen it before and every
time you use it first grip the steel
feel really comfortable about holding
the still imagine you're holding a
tennis racket or you're playing squash
you've got to be really comfortable with
it now 45 degrees confident grip
confident grip with the knife this is
the butt of the steel really important
you keep your fingers behind there you
never grip a steel with your fingers
over that because the knife comes back
in you've just lost a finger always grip
behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade
over still
stroke
and we start from the bottom to the top
so there
across
there
across
slow strokes over the top of the steel
and then come back underneath
then back in the knees
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is 10 times quicker more efficient
now
that's ready to start chopping
to stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath
now you can chop with confidence
[Music]
my next top tip is get the most out of
your humble veg peeler
it's brilliant for slicing ultra thin
ribbons or veg perfect for asian dishes
great for making long delicate parmesan
shavings to top soups and salads
it also makes wonderful chocolate curls
your pepper mill is more versatile than
you might think
tighten the top screw to get finely
ground pepper ideal for soups and sauces
[Music]
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground so set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
[Music]
peeling garlic for one clove simply bash
it with the back of a knife and the skin
comes off easily
for a whole head crush separate into a
bowl
cover and shake hard for about 10
seconds
then simply pick out the peeled cloves
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on
i'll be showing you a roast chicken
recipe to die for hold the drum and
slice straight through
but first like any good chef i'm always
looking to get great ingredients at the
right price
my shopping mantra is simple first rely
on your senses make sure whatever you're
buying it looks smells and really feels
good and if you get the chance taste it
before you buy it second is to recognize
that knowledge is crucial the more you
know about where your ingredients come
from and how they produce the better so
ask lots of questions and learn
you're never too old to learn from
experts and when it comes to buying
great birds one person knows what to
look for is award-winning fifth
generation master butcher danny lid gain
poultry is a great meat because there's
many different types of birds it's worth
tasting the variation of flavours
between different birds to birds is
massive
turkey's a great lean meat that's
available all year round not just for
christmas anybody who's worried about
eating fatty meats it's a really healthy
flavoursome meal
game birds people don't try them often
enough once they're shot they're hung up
for a little while but a few days at
least it means the meat's going to be
more tender it all adds flavor to the
birds
we've got a wood pigeon and a red leg
partridge both really good and cook
really quickly
when you're buying a chicken some of the
things to look out for is obviously the
smell
and when you're smelling a good quality
chicken you can tell the difference the
skin's a nice white color and it smells
like a fresh chickeny smell
when you're buying from a good butcher
you'll find you tend to get the giblets
as well which is basically the neck and
other organs this is great for making
gravy once you have cooked it you can
use all the offcuts for other things
stir fries curries pasta dishes save the
bones use the bones for stocks and soups
they're really packed full of flavor
and remember there are lots of different
breeds of chicken all have different
characteristics and flavors so shop
around and find the ones you love here
are three of my all-time favorites
the label anglais
these come from an old british breed
they've got smaller breasts but the
meat's delicious
the black leg a fantastic french variety
succulent with bags of flavour and
really meaty thighs
and the pulley device this is the rolls
royce of chickens rich gamey and
delicious one for special occasions
i think people should maybe try and buy
less meat but aim for the best quality
you're only going to get out what you
put in by putting the best quality into
a dish you're going to get the best
results
no matter how seasoned the chef you are
there are always new ingredients and
recipes to get fired up about
so if a tired old recipe is getting you
down spice it up with fresh ideas and
flavors
my next recipe is an old classic roast
chicken but with a simple twist it takes
on a new life and it's guaranteed to
impress
one of the things i love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines
start off with the stuffing
it's amazing how exciting a stuffed
roast chicken can be because it keeps
the chicken incredibly moist and gives a
delicious texture inside the bird
i'm going to start off with cured
cerrito this is a traditional spanish
sausage
and it's
garlicky spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing
get our chriso in
start cooking that down and getting all
those oils out
a little touch of olive oil in there to
get it going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the cerezo and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor
that lovely spiciness has been stolen
from that sausage now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlicky
fresh thyme just hold it down and put
your fingers on there and it's a really
nice way of taking off all those nice
fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it crackling in the
background
these are cannellini beans
they're waxy
very soft
not so delicious but very dense
but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down drain them off
in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from the freezer i'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
i mean that looks like it's
a dish on its own
good enough to eat now
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
tomatoes half dried
in
that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything
looks spanish it looks delicious
now
stuffing the chicken i like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wing tips
as well
salt pepper
so important
now
you're stuffing
i'm gonna go right inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces in the carcass
and take a nice large lemon
push the lemon in
pick up the person's nose pull the skin
over
olive oil on top
salt
and pepper
a teaspoon of paprika
sprinkle it on and then get your hands
and sort of
rub that in
let's see what the paprika is doing to
the chicken putting this like sweet
spicy marinade
it's not even roasted yet but it looks
delicious
[Music]
400ml of white wine same quantity of
water that helps the chicken to steam
chicken in
be generous with the time sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy
into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice take it out and remove the
full lid then give it another 30 minutes
to crisp up that skin
[Music]
look at that
it's so important to make sure you take
that tin foil off with half an hour to
go
beautiful
pierce that open
squeeze it in
that delicious gravy mix that into the
tray
and sieve that
that's really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible i'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day
and then just get your chicken roasting
juices
now
to cut the chicken up
hold the drum
and slice straight through
and there's a wonderful drum and the
thigh through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture
of that amazing rice chicken
just take my cooking juices just want to
give a really nice sort of lemony
flavor
over my chicken and there you go
a delicious
very charming stuffed
roast chicken
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking